los países europeos quieren acelerar la
campaña de vacunación que ya lleva dos
meses pero que aún no ha podido ser
posible conseguir esa ansiada velocidad
de crucero por ello los gobiernos
europeos envían hoy un mensaje de que no
es posible ya ralentizar más esta
campaña y que si es necesario se
aumentarán los fondos y también la
creación de nuevas plantas de producción
para que haya más vacunas disponibles y
es que los países europeos están viendo
de reojo como países como eeuu reino
unido e israel están tomando la
delantera en la vacunación mundial aun
así los gobiernos europeos siguen siendo
positivos creen que será posible
inmunizar al 70 por ciento de la
población europea de aquí a finales de
verano y más aún cuando se espera que
pueda aprobarse la vacuna de johnson and
johnson a mediados de marzo y también
contar con la vacuna de cure back en
junio pero aún así ante el peligro que
suscitan las nuevas variantes las
fronteras seguirán con restricciones de
hecho los viajes no esenciales
sin aconsejar se dentro de la unión
europea ante este peligro de las nuevas
variantes y más aún cuando la vacunación
no está siendo tan rápida aún está a la
espera de lo que pueda ocurrir en verano
algunos países europeos están ya
pidiendo certificados de vacunación para
que sea más fácil la movilidad dentro de
la unión europea aunque el debate aún
sigue abierto